what people say that children are our
future but this year we've seen that
they're also our competition please
welcome from Little Miss Sunshine Oscar
nominee
Abigail Breslin and from the pursuit of
happiness Jaden Christopher's sire Smith
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you have a good time working with
your dad
well no because he tricked me I thought
it was a comedy but it was actually a
drama what does your dad do
he's a computer systems analyst and
support technician consultant but what
does he do
I have no idea he's in the category for
the best animated short the Danish book
tour Eelco lifted gary Rydstrom a little
magical Roger Allers and Don Juan
maestro
jeiza M took no time for nuts Christian
oh and Michael Thurmond and the Oscar
goes to the Danish poet
[Applause]
[Music]
toriel Cove spent four years examining
genetic makeup of bringing coincidences
life choices missed opportunities and
lucky breaks to answer the question how
did I get here
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you first I have to apologize
to Tom Hanks because I did bring a list
just in case but I want to thank the
Academy for this wonderful award is such
an honor and also for continuing to
support this animated short category
that really means a lot to us I want to
thank the National Film Board of Canada
and all the funders and supporters in
Norway for helping us make this film my
producers Marcy Paige and Lisa finally
of make her film in Norway I want to
thank legal men for it for a
disreputable narration that was really
amazing in her to participate in this
and for everyone else who helped make me
this film I just want to say thank you
thank you thank you you know who you are
I know you who are and I know that
without you I wouldn't be standing here
with this little guy thank you very much
[Music]
so now we're here to present another
award for something short I know you
think they'd let us at least do one for
joke please which is sophisticated
here are the nominees in the category of
Best live action short beam saw and the
great idea
Dean SOT a look on it there Xavier
Malisse mom's own era most focused one
too many
Borja Kobe Agha Tom her son John Phil
mark and Ken Magnuson the Savior
Peter templeman and Stuart Perkins West
Bank story re stand down and the Oscar
goes to in the Wiz West Bank story
re-sand out filmed in california during
a wildfire had to stop shooting every
few minutes as helicopters flew overhead
to drop water on the blaze
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
I made a comedy musical about Israelis
and Palestinians that takes place
between two falafel stands and the West
Bank and it's a movie about peace and
about hope and to be able to get this
award just goes to show that there's so
many other people out there who support
that notion that when it comes to the
situation between Israelis and
Palestinians hope is not hopeless and on
another note I know a lot of people in
America are probably watching and asking
what are the short films well a lot of
them are made by directors who are
trying to get notice and I think in a
lot of ways we represent a little guy
because we don't have big studios behind
us or big-name actors or a lot of times
the budgets we need and it relies on
perseverance and stick-to-itiveness and
hustle and a dedication and loyalty from
a cast and crew who are doing it for
pennies if not for nothing so I'd be
remiss if I were to take this word and
not thank my co-writer Kim Ray my
producers Pascal Vidal Z Amy Kim Ashley
Jordan Ravi Malhotra and my composer
you've all run and last but not least
the two people who never doubted me even
when I doubted myself my mother who's
here in the audience Cathy my father is
watching I love you thank you
[Music]